foreign
[Music]
ERS editorial manager
in this episode we'll be discussing the
topic of Pride what is its purpose why
do some feel disillusioned by It While
others are embraced by it I'm joined by
The Spectators associate editor and
columnist Douglas Murray and feminist
campaigner and writer Julie bendon Julie
I'd like to turn to you first you've
written for spectator online multiple
times about Pride you've attended
Pride's marches and pride-like events
um
would you recall some of your earliest
memories of Pride well I do remember the
first Pride March
I went on which is about
1980 so I would have been
um
I traveled from Leeds to London and it
was a very political
occasion so it wasn't the kind of
heterosexuals coming out to
go up or have their own party
and at that time we really really did
need some very specific events for the
lesbian and gay community as it kind of
almost was then it was almost a kind of
cohesive community
because what what
bonded us together was the necessity to
fight for our legal rights which of
course we didn't have but also for
lesbians who weren't targeted
by any legislation as such to fight in
the family courts for example when we
lost custody of our children often to
Violent male ex-partners for the simple
reason that we were lesbian so there was
a lot there was lots happening very
direct discrimination and of course
we've just seen the end of the
um honeymoon period in the Gay
Liberation Front because the lesbians
had walked out getting sick of the
sexism
of the men so here we are you know
different century
same [__] anyway so it was it was good
fun but I do remember thinking that we
didn't quite fit together as lesbians
with some of the gay men and their
demands and there was a little bit of a
kind of being
gelled together like a broken teapot lid
was that a specific Turning Point
perhaps where you began noticing that
that perhaps this
togetherness where the community isn't
quite working
well actually and I don't mean this in
any disrespectful or rude way to my gay
brothers but we never ever asked to
become lesbian and gay
we had very different needs very
different lifestyle choices different
restrictions we were targeted by sexism
as well as anti-lesbian Prejudice we
were coerced into marriage of course we
had male violence to contend and some of
that sexism of course came from gay men
we were fighting
um the normalization of pornography
whereas this was abundant within some
gay male culture the kind of
commercialized gay male culture
and so we didn't ask to become lesbian
and gay and that was particularly I
think solidified
during the campaign against section 28.
later on in the 1980s where
there were many gay men who were quite
hysterical about it talking about there
was one article I remember reading
that was headlined the road to Auschwitz
and it you know it was a horrific piece
of legislation but please you know this
was completely Beyond The Pale bearing
in mind what gay men had had to concede
had had to deal with prior to that in
terms of being kicked out of their homes
losing their jobs
and of course we're talking at that
stage about a peak in the um in the AIDS
uh epidemic and lesbians of course had
huge problems to contend with and we
decided that actually we wanted to have
our own March which was lesbian strength
that had been organized from 1983.
so we would go on Pride marches and we'd
have a laugh with our gay male friends
and we'd have a bit of a party because
obviously gay men liked to party and
then you know we'd also have our own
March where we it was quite a bit more
political
and I do remember groups of gay men
standing on the corner where our March
was passing by clapping and cheering
and just being really supportive and
that was lovely that was really nice
Douglas um can I bring you in on this
topic what are your views on the
grouping of lesbians gays bisexual now
trans to form the LGBT
well I basically say the same view as
Julia which is lesbians and gay men
didn't have very much in common from the
outset had totally different demands
totally different interests and much
more uh my view and I've said this quite
often in recent years is that the whole
of what Dave Chappelle calls the
alphabet people uh Carr has become a
clown car because none of it fits
together the first two letters don't fit
together very well the lesbians of the
gays don't have very much in common
everyone's suspicious of bisexuals uh um
a lot a lot of people just don't believe
they exist particularly uh or at least
think that it's you know buy now gay
later as they used to say
um then then the trans people come along
they have nothing in common with any of
the other people in the grouping uh
because that's about the mysterious
gender unicorn nonsense where you can
suddenly be whatever sex you want to be
depending on how you feel that morning
when you get out of bed which has
nothing to do with being gay or being
lesbian which is certainly not a choice
because who wants the choice of
certainly for most of uh history making
their life a bit harder so the tea
people come along and help turn it into
a total clown car and then you get the
disaster of the the thing extending and
extending until you get the asexuals uh
thrown in as I always like to say
there's no bigger difference in nature
than that between asexuals and gay men
um you get you you get in this
two-spirit people or what's that it's
something to do with Native Americans
okay what if Native Americans uh got to
do with lesbians in Brighton and London
nothing at all in other words this has
just become a great big messy soup of a
people's mainly in recent years of
people saying I want a bit of that I've
objected actually to it most of my life
to the whole pride thing uh mainly on
taste grounds it has to be said I I
don't mind I very much enjoy having a
party most I don't begrudge anyone
having a party I do begrudge people
mistaking their sexuality for some
massively important signifier which
demands that other people then not just
respect them but pay them some special
dues and actually in actual fact you
could see this so that I've stumbled
across Pride a couple of times in my
time I've never gone but I've stumbled
across it a few times and one of the
things that's on a simple matter of
Aesthetics and taste that I deeply
dislike is seeing a bunch of of disco
gays on top of a bus waving to the
public as if they're celebrities sorry
love you're not a celebrity you're just
gay that's all and you shouldn't treat
the general public as your audience
waiting for them to celebrate the
Magnificent wonderful you so I think
there's just this nice the narcissism at
the heart of this uh and uh I've I've
got no time for it and just one other
quick Point uh I I actually very much
Julie and I I'm sure disagree on lots of
things she's uh of the political left
and uh I'm not
um and um I'm sure we disagree on lots
of things but one thing we absolutely I
think find ourselves in agreement with
on is that there's a new misogyny
wrapped up in this movement now and if
anyone wants to see that they can see
the fact and I I can't stress this
enough I try to stress it wherever I go
these days but I say things about trans
issues which uh Julie says which JK
Rowling and others say and I get
absolutely no blowback I mean partly I
don't care anyway but the point is is
that I get no blame I don't get mad
purple head Maniacs gluing themselves to
the floor when I speak in public uh
Julie bindle gets the threats gets JK
Rowling gets some Kathleen stock gets
some if anyone wants an absolute proof
of this there's a a disgusting uh um
website that is the result the residue
of a defunct gay paper called pink news
run by a pseudo-journalist called Ben
something or other they have run
thousands thousands and thousands of
articles in recent years attacking JK
Rowling basically as the devil incarnate
she holds precisely the same views on
trans that I do she holds precisely the
same views on trans as her fellow
Scottish writer Irvin Welsh does how
many times has pink news attacked Irvin
Welsh zero they believe and this is a
very important point if I can say so the
weird alphabet people clown car people
believe that they should be allowed to
control lesbians and gays and women in
particular they believe that if we don't
have precisely the locks that views they
have we are traitors and the people that
they believe they should have the right
to control the most are women they are
so disgusting these people
I I of course agree the misogyny is Rife
and I also haven't been on a pride March
for a very very long time I got sick of
the roller skating nuns and I got sick I
mean no you know obviously each to their
own I didn't want to see men's hairy
asses hanging out of their leather chaps
I just didn't and still don't and also
I'm delighted to say that thank you for
mentioning pink news because I did in
fact sue them the definition
um and we settled after 18 months of
litigation where I'd love to think I
handed them their ass in those chaps but
to talk about the the hellish kind of
clown car which is a great phrase
Douglas I love that the lgbtqi two
Spirit Plus now is resembling uh more of
a an unbreakable Wi-Fi code than it is
anything that is that speaks to a
same-sex attracted people which is of
course what we should be talking about
we we have something in common even
though you know one side of men and one
side of women
the gender wurus that have come in are
just absolutely Bonkers and you're right
that they target women they target
lesbians in particular they really hate
us
they target women because because if you
think about the clever ruse of trans
activism what it's done is it's its
position knee as they would say a CIS
woman as the oppressor of a trans woman
so therefore the oppressor class the
privileged class whether you believe in
patriarchy or not whether you think
women are oppressed we all know that
there's a disadvantage that women face
in life compared to like men and
we are now the oppressor of men who
identify as women now Rachel dollizell
wasn't allowed to do that
um the white woman who masqueraded uh as
having African Heritage she was not
allowed in fact she was the biggest
villain that had ever walked the Earth
so why is that and my answer is this
it's just a new men's Rights Movement
but this time is populated in the main
and I'm not letting the right wing off
the hook for misogyny not at all but
it's populated in the main by men who
claim to be leftists Owen Jones for
example
who say that they're Progressive but I
think in my mind my opinion really hate
women
that are too big for our boots yeah so
long as they're shouting the loudest and
we're in tow they don't mind but my god
do they hate us feminists and they give
us a good kicking via the trans ideology
and the the um the slur of transphobia
and I mean yeah we've all heard um
and actually been asleep for for four
days the latest docsfun Scandal another
charity completely captured by Stonewall
completely captured by trans ideology
dominated by privileged kids without a
brain in their heads that have left
University where they haven't been
taught to think critically they've been
taught that thinking critically is
dangerous and that they'll be finished
if they do so they then go into senior
positions at charity Cyclops Farm we've
seen the Bedrock of misogyny there we
saw that with the Haiti Scandal where
there were
um wealthy highly paid Consultants
working for Oxfam raping children I will
not call them sex workers I will not say
that these men were clients there were
raping children and leaving them a few
quid for doing so and Oxfam I heard
today from another whistleblower that
there was a huge argument going on
amongst the
lgbtqi2 Spirit Plus lot in Delhi in
India in their office about how these
men in Haiti hadn't done anything wrong
they had simply contributed to the local
economy like going to eat at one of the
local restaurants it's staggering and
this this colleague who is a lesbian
who's been called a CIS bigot
who fights for the rights of women and
that means against sexual exploitation
as well
she's critical of the sex industry
she was called now wait for it [__]
phobic
horror phobic for saying that men
shouldn't have the right to have sex to
rape vulnerable children and
she was then further told
that to speak out against the sex trade
was transphobic in essence because
many and I quote many trans women of
color are sex workers so where do we go
with this well I mean we literally think
that they rule the roost
yeah that's uh there's always a new
Circle that you can look down to isn't
there and that that's a great example of
one Julie
um I I mean groups like Oxfam have has
been demonstrated this week they've all
just been suffused by this this is just
washed across uh the charitable sector
as every other sector and and it it's
partly because of course it's not just
the ill education of the people that the
audit is describing it's also the fact
that so much of this discussion has been
shut down for so long and it's part of a
wider societal issue which is the again
something I've talked about a lot in
recent years which is the transformation
of our societies from societies that uh
that admire and validate heroism into
societies that admire and seek to have
victimhood and so the 2ia GQ plus LG uh
bus people are basically a group of
people who want victimhood well screw
that I'm not a victim Julie's done not a
victim we're not victims we don't live
our lives as victims ah but there's a
certain type of of heterosexual male in
particular who wants a bit of the
victimhood's pie they have the disaster
and it is a disaster in our era to be
born a white CIS heterosexual male
they've got this terrifying disadvantage
from the first of their life which is
that they can't claim victimhood but now
you can there was a a sort of low-grade
lecturer at University of Oxford a few
years ago who said that he was uh
congratulated by a student who said it's
so wonderful to see myself represented
by a tutor as a queer student the
tutoring question apparently I think put
nail polish on or something and is
married to a woman sorry you're not
queer you're boringly straight you're
just straight and that's fine you know
know some of my best friends are
straight I don't think there's anything
wrong with it I think we should all Live
and Let Live but this guy has realized
in our era to be straight that's not
enough so he's like thinks oh I'll paint
my nails and then I'll call myself queer
sorry and also for some of us queer
isn't a nice word we didn't like you
hearing that word we didn't like hearing
that word from straight people when it
was heard that gay people in the street
and we don't like it being used by
straight people who want a bit of the
sodding victimhood pie and that's what
we're seeing yeah I agree this is
terrible I'm agreeing with Douglas all
the way through this it sounds terrible
it's absolutely normal you're bound to
say something really offensive soon
but you know I saw on the wonderful
Hadley Friedman give an interview on
times radio where she was talking about
the absurdity of the the holy month of
Pride and about how you know Oxfam with
its new
lgbtqi video in which it called
middle-aged women turfs and just full of
hate was trying to out woke itself and
obviously spent quite a lot of money did
Oxfam on this video and you know taking
food out of the mouth of the children
it's supposed to be helping but she she
pointed this out and
she's very funny sadly and she made
really astute points instantly little
talcum X Owen Jones is there saying that
they now have straight
people talking about Pride they have
straight people denigrating our month of
Pride well
first of all how does he know that
Hadley doesn't occasionally dye her hair
blue which would make her queer and
secondly
what what is the cue right are they are
they it's just straight men that like
strangling women till they pass out are
they straight men that are so queer they
don't wash their car on a Sunday
who are the aromantics and asexuals in
what way does that make them queer I
know lots of single people who can't be
asked can't be [__] to have a
relationship maybe not even sex
what on Earth does what makes them queer
most of the queer identify people on
that rainbow list are heterosexuals yeah
with whatever Daft hair do oh and let's
add one other to the list which is a
totally fictitious group that call
themselves non-binary
means look at me look at me uh I want
attention I'm coming out of non-binary
and they always say oh I've got a big
announcement I've really been I I mean
like guys like I've been I've been like
waiting for ages and I'm trying to build
up the courage but I'm non-binary
okay well that's about the biggest
boring announcement anyone can make
there is no satisfactory definition of
non-binary that I've come across apart
from look at me and the idea that that I
mean obviously um he her they them Sam
Smith uh Blair
um he uh constantly announces that he's
non-binary and his as Andrew Doyle said
as far as we can see uh uh Sam Smith's
idea of being non-binary is that he's
he's a big big fat ugly bloke uh who
occasionally dresses like uh a hoe and
uh dances like a hoe around a pole and
that's his feminine side well that's a
lovely thing for all the women in the
world isn't it isn't that just Charming
uh um whenever you pole dance that's
your that's you representing all the
women in the world great work I mean
this is this is the thing is this is old
style you know they all think they're
breaking boundaries and they're not they
are reinforcing some of the most
intolerably basic boundaries we ever had
to contend with you know you your
daughter likes blue get her on hormone
therapy you know your son likes reading
a girl
it's so aggressive and I remember when I
first started researching the topic of
transsexuality as we used to be allowed
to call it this was back in 2003 because
I'd seen some
article in a newspaper about this Brave
and stunning
um man male teacher that had gone back
to school as a woman and that the pupils
the students were all calling him Miss
Jones or whatever and I thought hang on
a minute is this still going on this is
seen as something really Progressive and
it's seen as something akin to coming
out as lesbian or gay
and why why is this so anyway I got on
the case
ended up going to a store called
Transformations which was on in Houston
but there were several branches around
the country and what Transformations was
it was a place where cross-dressing men
who get a sexual kick from
cross-dressing go to be dressed by these
poor female shop assistants
they get made up it's all online now
which is a terrible shame so I spent the
day at Transformations talking to the
customers talking to the women they
found it utterly grotesque that these
Sean Connery type dudes would come in
and want to wear the most ridiculous
outfits that they had a police Woman's
outfit they had a bridal department they
had nurses uniforms I mean sexual fetish
or what and you know size 12 stilettos
and there was a glass cabinet with all
the accoutrement on in there such as a
rubber vagina for men to put over their
dongers so they could
um go to the Loo sitting down now this
is the thing that upset me the most
there were some pills
that they could buy over the counter
that brought on apparently
symptoms feelings every month of
pre-menstrual tension that's period
pains for those who don't know now we
spent our time
as young women trying to find a cure for
that
these men want to experience it and the
sexual stereotyping and the misogyny
just in that room
um was staggering and I just thought
these 1950s psychiatrists
that see actual gender non-conformity in
other words a woman like me
a man like you we do not fit the
stereotypes that were set out for men
and women
the the whole kind of Adam and Eve stuff
but that's wrong as you say Douglas that
has to be corrected with the surgeon's
knife the whole the whole project of
feminism is to get rid of these rules in
these stereotypes which is what many gay
men have been arguing as well we can be
as we want
we don't have to conform just last week
I noticed something quite interesting
um a couple examples actually you had
the U.S Navy who decided to change their
Twitter and I believe Facebook Banner to
support Pride
um but in a matter of hours actually
they took it down they removed it and a
similar thing happened with major major
league baseball I believe
um what do you think is going on here
why are companies and organizations
toying with these
Pride Flags which there are many
variations of now but what do you think
is going on here
well if I can say first I I wrote about
this a bit in a book a couple of books
about The Madness of crowds uh you can
actually trace the rise in this nonsense
uh uh in into the absolute flooding
across the mainstream to the post-2008
financial disaster
um the banks the major corporations
people who should have been on the line
for what they did to the economy and
almost completely destroying the world
economy ended up discovering that a much
easier way and a cheaper way uh to
improve their image after 2008 was to go
very very big on all the identity
politics stuff you know Coots bank for
instance just a single one out the
Queen's bank is now covered in Pride
flags at the front of the of the office
and say a safe environment for all of
our come on Coots has had gays working
there for years it's not been a problem
but they go big on it they go big on it
after the the victories have been won
you know I'm afraid that you know the
American Military was wasn't great on
gay rights up until yesterday they
weren't great on gay rights when I was
growing up when you couldn't be in the
American Military and be openly gay
um so so they all jump onto the
bandwagon after it's actually
effectively finished and then they've
them I've
said that this is like watching a train
nicely pulling into its destination
station and then suddenly getting ahead
of steam going shooting off the tracks
and off the rails and that's effectively
what's happened the
transformation of a pride March into a
pride day into a pride week into a pride
month uh you know as if this is an
ancient and well-known holiday that we
all respect when a bunch of poor
straight people end up having to sort of
wave rainbow flags and do things that
gays don't do
um and and and it's all the cynical
corporates and the great thing that has
started to happen is that we the public
are on to them you know some years ago I
wrote in a spectator about my bank
Barclays uh you know they had this big
campaign saying you know love is what a
love uh happens here that was their
slogan with a big rainbow I said I don't
want love to happen at my bank I just
don't want you to charge me extra money
when I lose my back statements oh and
also be quite nice if you gave some
rewards for Savers but anyway they can't
do any of that stuff that banks used to
do but apparently I can find love at
Barclays in my local branch oh but there
aren't any branches anymore so it makes
it even harder anyway the point is they
can't do the base job they were set up
to do so they do all this crap the great
thing is that we the public are on to
them now and that's why we've seen
things like major league baseball start
to reverse course because they've seen a
couple of cases we've had a big one with
the Dilla Mulvaney one in the U.S uh
where uh Bud Light gave this endorsement
to this uh trans look at me person and
uh the most one of the biggest attention
seekers in uh in America these days and
uh Bud uh Bud shares have gone down by a
quarter because people have abandoned
the brand they don't like it uh same
thing with Target one of the big
retailers in the US they've been going
huge on pride month including
um swimwear for children and women that
includes the opportunity to tuck your
male genitalia into the swimsuit again
it's the women being disadvantaged it's
not happening with men's swimsuits but
Target is now also as it were the target
of a campaign the other way what we're
really seeing is the beginning of the
back Clash against this nonsense we are
and
it's money obviously
and it's the Stonewall protection racket
yeah that means that once a company or
in an organization a charity an NGO
whoever
buys into that protection racket
then they have to do all of it and of
course because the flag has become more
and more ridiculous every single year
where they have added I mean I was torn
limb from limb for saying this by some
of the trans activists the trans Taliban
but they are including the likes of maps
minor attracted persons in other words
those that want to have sex with
children
then I've seen as queer and they're seen
and we've we know this through Academia
there are at least two or three quite
senior academics who have looked at the
Discrimination towards those that wish
to form relationships they would say and
I would say sexually assault children
underage kids and so they're now
involved and every time I see a new
stripe I think what next what now what
the hell are we looking at and it has
lost all meaning it's lost every single
bit of political emphasis that it had
and what on Earth
are we we're seeing
when we look at Camden Council
with pink and blue the trans flag
as a zebra Crossing
I mean you know Kathleen stock and I set
up the lesbian project
but she's a bit like a think tank to
look at the way that lesbians are
completely ignored
uh pretty much when it comes to the
funding when it comes to research
because we're subsumed within this
atrocity of the lgbtqi lot and we had
our first
um brilliant meeting packed out meeting
and
we were picketed of course by the blue
Fringe mob dancing and singing and
shouting and knocking people's phones
out of their hands when they went up to
them to ask what they were doing
and we finally got away from them we'd
had a great day and they're in front of
us was the rainbow flag on the I
couldn't believe it we had to cross the
road on that rainbow flag and I just
thought it it is the world's gone
Bonkers times
1028. but of course the flat of the flag
went went Bonkers when a few years ago
has decided to add the black and the
brown Stripes which was a massive
category error because it was suggested
that without the black and the brown
Stripes black and brown people weren't
represented in the flag well of course
like who did they think the yellow
stripes represented or the orange ones
or or the red ones or the blue ones was
it the Smurfs were represented or what
like people from Scotland when they've
been in the Sun a bit too long like what
do they think this these Stripes were at
the beginning they weren't about race so
that was the beginning of it but the
main thing I just like to say is is this
all of the all of this is about a really
appalling way to limit the way in which
we see people and the way in which we
see ourselves
uh there are no such thing as members of
the lgbtqia community there is no such
thing as that community and when I say
this I've already explained why I think
there's no such thing as that Community
but there are no such thing as these
people there are people who happen to be
gay like me there are people who happen
to be straight
so what that is the least interesting
thing it's about as interesting as the
color of your hair and what is happening
is we are telling a new generation of
people apart from the fact you everyone
can join the great rainbow magical
unicorn people apart from that we're
saying this will Define your life and it
shouldn't it shouldn't it is the
beginning of your life not in any way
the be all and end-all of it and we are
making people victims we are making them
limit what they can do in their lives
what they should seek to Aspire to it
doesn't matter what your sexuality is
you should Simply Be concentrating on
doing what you should be doing in your
life and doing it well Douglas can I can
I just ask um
what would you say to those what is your
view on those people who perhaps
celebrate Pride or attend Pride events
because it gives them a sense of
belonging perhaps because
despite having legal equality there are
still some stigma in society and growing
up can sometimes be tough and it it does
provide an opportunity for people to
meet one another who have shared similar
experiences there's a massive number of
ways you can meet other people who've
had the same experiences and you can go
to a gay bar you can go on any app you
can meet a group of friends you can meet
A Wider Circle of people you can move to
an area where there's more people like
you uh uh um all sorts of things I I
mean the idea that anything meaningful
is achieved uh from uh the great float
parade and uh Rave at the end of the day
and that somehow makes the community is
absolute nonsense I would say there was
a sense of community at a time in the
past as Julia firstly when there were
specific things that needed campaigning
for and there was some unity in those
days including between lesbians and gays
when when rights were not there but
we're in the post rights struggle a part
of this now and and and so you know I
don't care if people want to find their
meaning in a in a great float parade and
day-long disc I don't care they're
welcome to do it what they should not
have the right to do is to say this is
the only way of being gay uh I had some
uh little um uh weirdo uh uh uh guy say
to me on a show the other day I was with
Piers Morgan and this this weirdo
non-entity comedian said something he
said uh he described me as being
straight he said are you another CIS
white straight male and I said well
you've actually got that one Ron and
immediately uh he said I was the worst
type of gay so it's quite interesting
the way these people can immediately
flip you from being straight to the
worst type of game but my point is I
don't think these people have the rights
of excommunication I don't think they
have the right of representation
Stonewall is a racket it is a racket
that should have been shut down years
ago it Opera rates like the mob it goes
the politicians and saying nice career
you've got here shame if anything
happened to it it does the same thing
with corporations Stonewall is a
disgrace pink news is a disgrace these
things should be defunct they do not
speak for me they do not speak for Julie
in fact they attack people like us and
my point is we do not have the situation
as gays of
take me to your leader
that's the worst one the take me to your
leader sorry these weird malfunctioning
inadequates who pretend to speak for
people they don't know have no right to
speak for a community they don't even
understand and that doesn't in the end
exist that's what I mind exactly and
when I'm described as lgbtq I say how
dare you first of all how can I be all
those things at once I don't have the
time secondly how dare you
um call me anything other than my own
definition of myself which is first and
foremost a human being as you say
Douglas and a lesbian imagine if
Kathleen stock and I decided to take a
little trip down to the pride March or
one of the pride events we would be torn
from Lim
we would be absolutely vilified we would
probably be attacked we'd be surrounded
we'd be heckled there would be hell to
pay it would be a terrifying experience
and we are two lesbians who have fought
for lesbian Liberation who have set up
the lesbian project and who believe in
the rights of women and all human beings
to exist without discrimination but we
would be under attack as though we were
um some kind of crazed evangelists
coming over to try to and all up and it
would be worse Julie all of this would
be done to you by the people saying love
is love that's right love will love wins
love wins especially when you're beating
up lesbians apparently
Douglas and Julie thank you so much for
joining us
[Music]
all right